which title on YouTube it's pretty good
it's funny huh you just hate having a
job that's the craziest thing hey what
is going on youtube welcome back to
another I don't know what the [ __ ] this
is but hey just to start off this day I
do want to say [ __ ] banessa for that
stupid-ass [ __ ] costume that she had
and after this episode she supplier Oh
with my birth today I just offends you
but I don't have scoliosis so I just
have to walk with a [ __ ] crooked ass
walk a little too far so today we are
going to be reviewing Oh God
four of the worst Japanese teas ever I
don't know what this is but this is
actually something that muriel brought
to me from japan i don't know what this
is but it's supposed to be ridiculous
just by the looks of it this one has a
lobster with poison inside that one has
a Satan's puzzle in there this right
here is clearly it's going to be hot and
this one smells like the bottom of a
neces feet personally I'm not a very
cocky person but I will say this there's
not a lot of things in this world that
scare me and there's not a lot of things
that you could feed me that'll have me
either throw up or have me freak out
because you know I'm gangster like that
throw up the West Side [ __ ] what are
you shaking your [ __ ] head for here
we go boom here we have it fo hot
glasses the wall job Gina don't Dana we
got each of these right in front of it
let's do this from the right all the way
to the left because these two I don't
know what the [ __ ] they are um let's see
if you read this in Japanese it says you
they're going to die chorionic a second
mother pop girl here we go oh this is
high-quality plastic to Chapman
people kid toe never fail with the high
quality stuff uh-oh there's two there's
two of these I actually thought it was
gonna be a tea packet this is kind of
surprised do I just dump this into the
hot water oh you know what it doesn't
smell that bad just mother green tea
people tripping this is not as scary as
I thought it was gonna be boom it's just
a little green tea guys got me scared
it's just a little green tea a little
getting my chop just got to mix it in
like that I personally love green tea
green tea is actually one of my favorite
drinks to drink of all time it's
relaxing as antioxidants gets in your
system and it gives you a nice caffeine
height throughout the whole day does it
bring you up and it doesn't make you
crash and this my friend it's just like
in my shot said the bed it's ours [ __ ]
I know [ __ ] [ __ ] don't you got to
make sure you add another packet just to
make sure it's bosses [ __ ] like that
when it hits the hot water it's this
it's a different smell profile it's not
getting my shot anymore it's al it's
sour sour is [ __ ] but I know [ __ ]
[ __ ] which is why [ __ ]
I double up the pack oh yeah [ __ ] what
anybody says I was a born no [ __ ] angle
B no [ __ ] if you've ever left like any
type of like protein like chicken in the
fridge for like a month and it kind of
has like that goopy like broken down
protein like moldy smell that's what
this [ __ ] some of like
Vanessa you want to try it first great
it smells like old chicken like old
protein like if you've ever left like
any type of protein like chicken pork
beef in the fridge for a very long time
it has that that mildewy like just
fermented I can't help but laugh I don't
want to do this
[Laughter]
that's our spot oh oh oh it's like
saliva is coming out of my mouth but no
so bad uh that was a lot worse than I
expected
why no [ __ ] oh my god that was one of
the worst things I literally almost
threw up on the spot just go to the gym
for about a couple hours sweat in that
[ __ ] make sure that you go to a human
ass place go to the sauna take your feet
squish it around and then put that suck
into somebody else's shoe dip it in hot
water squeeze I [ __ ] out and drink it
that's exactly what that [ __ ] is Vanessa
guess what you gotta try to cuz you
dressed up as me it's there oh you got
you decided to dress up as me you might
as well give it a go
just [ __ ] taste it then you throw up
just [ __ ] [ __ ] taste it or you're
fired
how about that do it no you can't
flavor-wise I don't think this one's
gonna be as bad but I will say this a
spicy food is not really my [ __ ] right
now I love the flavor of spicy food
however I'm not too like keen on having
it digest into my body because usually
if I eat spicy food it comes out like a
[ __ ] spikebat out of my [ __ ] for
this one I learned my lesson I am going
to be using one of these packets because
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy
it's green too I thought it'll be a
different color holy hell look at that
[Music]
they have that same green tea flavor I
think that's the base of this is all
green tea or matcha tea just smells like
regular green tea it doesn't smell like
this which is jewel jewel is sour in
Vietnamese [ __ ] hell
gonna get this a sip not spicy it's not
too bad I could take this level of spice
like it's high Davis so ain't no puss
here's the thing people I tackle life
like I tackle food
I need scary [ __ ] you don't know what
you like and dislike until you try it
that's a life lesson that's what you're
supposed to take away from this
experience it just tastes like a nice
spicy matcha broth you know I'm saying
it's not bad smells great
[Music]
hot tickles down the throat a little bit
and that's a bet I actually like this
it's kind of like a spicy soup it just
sticks around to the pan back but that's
actually not as bad as I thought it was
oh it's not as bad as I thought it would
be oh I'm [ __ ] sweating from my nose
a little bit but this one's not bad
compared to that [ __ ] I could handle
this [ __ ] all day I'll even take another
drink oh you're flat little snip it just
tastes like spicy spicy group spicy
green tea that's all I [ __ ] with that I
wouldn't drink it for fun but sticks
with you number two wasn't too much of a
challenge as you can tell I tackled that
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] boss ain't
nothing to stop a neat little fireball
in my chest that's all next one don't
know what this is never pretended like I
do I don't even know what the drawing is
supposed to be I literally see it's
supposed to be worms or that's like
dirty laundry or caterpillars neat what
open it up to packets and like we
learned from the other one
we did double down [ __ ] same color
green and that goes mix it up and here
we have it I ain't scared of nothin and
I'm gonna drink this [ __ ] nobody knows
what this is but it's green and it looks
crazy
smells like regular matcha there isn't
any sour notes to it a 2017 cheered in
the values of Taiwan a swell into a
barrel sommelier ah that's [ __ ]
bitter that tastes like tires you know
it's not as bad as the first one but it
has like this and kind of just coats
your mouth a little bit
hello so bitter what the [ __ ] dude it's
like somebody melted a pack of condoms
in there not that I've had a condom in
my mouth let me try that again
it's it it's bitter it's like you licked
the bottom of a shoe or you just put
like a whole bunch of [ __ ] rubber
bands in your mouth dude I mean I could
drink it a third time and I wouldn't
have liked the reaction I have with the
first one but yeah I think the thing
that's in this guy's mouth is probably
rubber bands then or some type of rubber
cuz it's very just it just kind of has
like that
I just coats your mouth I'm pretty sure
this is what a girl goes to and when
they sucked a dick through a condom
maybe Vanessa shaking her head cuz she
knows what's up [ __ ] [ __ ] she's like
yeah I know what that feels like
oh I got a little quick Oh God you know
what bucket we're just gonna roll
through number four don't know what this
is guys sweating there's a lobster and
there are a garbage can is employ'd fish
I have no idea what that correlates to
the flavor of this but once again as I
said before Davis Oh ain't no
[ __ ] [ __ ] whoa this what
[ __ ] smells weird
you smell that [ __ ] what oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
know this much about my straight up hot
garbage I think this one's [ __ ]
supposed to be garbage do look at the
color of this one it smells like [ __ ] it
actually smells like [ __ ] it smells like
a unwiped [ __ ]
what's up guess what Vanessa you're
drinking this one too yes you are
it's a part of your job description
wanna work for Davis Oh Carmody guess
what you have to drink assjuice it's not
so bad it makes me want a freestyle rap
about it yo listen listen I don't want
to drink this because the liquid smells
like extra piss matter of fact more than
piss I think this really smells like
massive [ __ ] like a massive [ __ ] in the
toilet I think it's gonna kill me right
now
Boyka Boyka Boyka
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you know what this one actually isn't
taste as bad as it smells
I'm kind of surprised it has an
aftertaste
that's like garbage it's not the initial
taste I don't think the taste is bad
it's like the air after you drink it
it's very reminiscent of garbage because
the original taste just tastes like I
don't know like grandma Asian medicine
but act or it's the smell that gets you
it maybe I'm tripping
[Music]
you got it's garbage it's not bad at
first I'm tell you it's not bad it's
just like after it sits in your mouth
it's just it reminds you of garbage so
it makes you want to yak when you hold
man when I burp I can taste it
oh I don't know about doing this type of
[ __ ] I don't know about this [ __ ] I
didn't think it was gonna be this bad
well that is the taste test of the four
worst Japanese teas on the face of this
planet what could I say
these two were the worst these two
weren't that bad this one was just
bitter so it made me want to spit it out
but [ __ ] the smell of this but the taste
in this together is the worst thing i
i've ever had in my life um enjoy if you
guys want me to [ __ ] hell try new
things review other products send it to
the PIO box the address is in the
description box below and let's get a
funky and crazy with it because I
[ __ ] I will see you next time I
got a [ __ ] yak oh my god
[Music]